vamos a practicar con estas divisiones y
ahora tenemos
qué tal 14
entre 70
y de entrada podemos ver que este será
un número décima ya que el 14 es mucho
menor que el 70 el 70 no no cabe dentro
del 14 tendremos algo en números
decimales
así es que haremos lo siguiente colocar
el punto decimal y añadir valores en los
decimales que en este caso serán 0
no quisimos
que serán ceros para que no afectemos el
valor este 14 sigue siendo 14 solo que
ahora tenemos decimales y es 14.00 esto
nos apoyará para que hagamos nuestra
división
nos aseguramos de tener el punto decimal
exactamente en el mismo lugar en nuestra
respuesta y tendremos 14 entre 70 será 0
como habíamos dicho 0 por 70 es igual a
0 14 - 0 es igual a 14 y bajamos el
primer valor decimal que hemos agregado
y bajamos este 0 140 entre 70 cuántas
veces nos cabe 70 dentro de 140 nos cabe
dos veces
y multiplicaremos 2 por 70 es igual a
140 140 140 nos queda 0 en este momento
ya tenemos un residuo de 0 lo que
implica que ya no vamos a seguir
dividiendo tenemos un número total
así es que podemos decir que 14 entre 70
es igual a 0.2 todos decimos vamos a
hacer un poco de espacio para hacer uno
más
qué tal que ahora tenemos 16 en tren
el número será bueno pongamos 25
16 / 25 como vamos a manejar esto
sabemos que el 16 es más pequeño que el
25 por lo tanto tendremos un resultado
con decimales colocaremos entonces el
punto decimal y añadiremos
algunos valores decimales para
para que este 16 nos permita hacer la
división entre 25 cuidado insisto no
estamos modificando el valor de 1616
sigue siendo igual que 16.000 ok nos
aseguramos de tener el punto decimal a
la misma altura y hagamos nuestra
división 16 entre 25 cuántas veces nos
cabe 25 en 1600 por 25 0 16 menos 0 es
igual a 16 y entonces tomaremos uno de
los valores
decimales que hemos añadido y bajaremos
ese primer cero
cuántas veces cabe 25 en 160 esto ya
puede ser divisible y entonces nos
preguntamos 25 por 4 es igual a 125 por
6 es igual a 150 quedará perfecto
66 por 25 150 y si hay 160 le restamos
150 tendremos 10
aún tenemos un residuo por lo que
podemos bajar un cero de estos decimales
cambio de color para que sea evidente y
ahora tenemos 100 100 entre 25 44 x 25
es igual a 100 si asciende el resto
siente tendré ahora si un residuo de 0 y
con eso tenemos nuestra respuesta 16
entre 25 será igual a 0 puntos 64